قد توفر مجموعة من الأدوية الجديدة
بعض الأمل والراحة للأشخاص
الذين يعانون من حالات طبية معينة في
وقت مبكر من عام 2023 ، أحد
أكثر المنتجات الجديدة المتوقعة هو
عقار لوكانوماب الذي لا يعالج
مرض الزهايمر ، لكن التجارب السريرية تظهر أنه
يبدو أنه يبطئ من تقدمه.  من
المرض بنسبة تصل إلى 27 في المائة
يقول الأطباء أن ذلك يمكن أن يمنح المرضى
نوعية حياة أطول ولكن هناك مخاوف
بشأن الآثار الجانبية المحتملة مثل
تورم الدماغ والنزيف سيظل الأشخاص
مستقرين عند مستوى وظائفهم الحالي
لفترة أطول من الوقت
ربما ستة أشهر حتى 12 شهرًا وبالنسبة
للأشخاص الذين يخططون لحياتهم
ويتعاملون مع الأنشطة اليومية ،
قد يكون هذا تأجيلًا ذا مغزى
لتدهور المرض ،
وهناك تقدم آخر محتمل في
الأعمال لحل مشكلة كانت النساء
تدوم التجارب السريرية لأجيال الأجيال على عقار جديد يُظهر fezolinatant أنه
يقلل بشكل كبير من شدة
وتواتر السخونة  يومض
العلاج غير الهرموني عن طريق الفم يمكن أن تتم الموافقة عليه من قِبل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) في
وقت مبكر من العام المقبل ، كما
يأمل باحثو Fall أن يكون لقاح RSV
متاحًا خاصة بعد
موجة العدوى التي تملأ المستشفيات
هذا العام ، وهناك العديد من اللقاحات
المرشحة التي تقترب من المراجعة في الولايات المتحدة
والتي يمكن أن تساعد  لحماية
صغار السن وكبار السن الذين هم أكثر
عرضة للمضاعفات من
عدوى الرئة هذه على الجبهة المرغوبة ،
ابحث عن مجموعة لقاح الإنفلونزا و covid-19
والتي يمكن أن تكون متاحة بحلول
موسم الإنفلونزا المقبل ، وتقوم إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية بدراسة
تطبيق للسماح بذلك  ناركان
بخاخ الأنف الذي يعكس الجرعات الزائدة من المواد الأفيونية
ليتم بيعها دون وصفة طبية ،
يقول خبراء الصناعة إن هناك شيئًا واحدًا
مؤكدًا تقريبًا لعام 2023 ،
سترتفع تكلفة الرعاية الصحية مع دراسة استقصائية
لشركات التأمين تتنبأ
بتكاليف الرعاية الصحية العالمية  زيادة بنسبة 10 في المائة في العام المقبل ،
تؤثر بعض هذه التكاليف على
المنتجات المستخدمة على نطاق واسع مثل لقاحات covid-19 الخلفية
تشير التقديرات إلى أن تكلفة
اللقاحات يمكن أن تتضاعف أربع مرات في الولايات المتحدة إذا
توقفت الحكومة الفيدرالية عن
توفيرها مجانًا
إليزابيث كوهين CNN.